we have a voicemail number which is 219
to david p you can call anytime if you
have a message for me this caller admits
to voting for kirsten cinema previously
and says she's ashamed for having done
it take a listen
hi david this is barb from tucson
arizona
and i am ashamed to say i personally
voted for kristin cinema when she ran
last time because she represented
herself as being a democrat which she
apparently is not she's just an
attention getting brat stomping her feet
and i'll tell you this i have personally
contacted the county democratic
headquarters and requested that they
start a recall petition we need to get
rid of her yeah you know the uh i
appreciate uh the caller for being
honest and uh being honest about her
shame
um i actually i know arizona has recalls
for legislators it has a mechanism i
can't tell from looking at it at it
whether it only applies to state
legislators or whether it would apply to
a representative in dc like kirsten
cinema i don't see it as likely and you
know why
cinema is still pretty popular in
arizona i know there's a lot about she's
just horrible and everybody hates her
federally she's not very popular in
arizona those are the folks who get to
vote
she's really not doing that poorly
um and so i i don't know whether that
recall would work but there are lots of
folks like this caller who say i did
vote for her
but i wouldn't next time and uh we'll
see what the future holds for kirsten
cinema we're gonna talk on the bonus
show today about major decisions
upcoming for the supreme court on guns
on abortion on death penalty
as the approval of the death penal of
the uh supreme court rather
is lower than it's been in decades we
will also talk about congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez's
pouncing on facebook and saying break
facebook up
in the wake of the major outage that
took uh place yesterday which affected
facebook as well as instagram and
whatsapp which we talked about at the
top of the show and we will talk about
lars vilks the muhammad cartoonist from
2007. he has died
in a car accident um
we will talk and review the entire
muhammad cartoon story all of those
stories on today's bonus show get
instant access by signing up at
joinpakman.com
we will see you then